we're putting the harshest strongest
most stringent sanctions on Iran I hope
to be able to make a deal with them a
good deal a fair deal a good deal for
them better for them better for them but
we cannot allow them to have nuclear
weapons we must be able to go to a site
and check that site we have to be able
to go into their military bases to see
whether or not they're cheating
that was the president earlier saying
the United States of America must never
ever allow Iran to have nuclear weapons
here with reaction he is the host of CR
T V levins TV he is the host right here
of the number-one show Sunday nights
10:00 p.m. and all of cable life liberty
and Levin and I call them the great one
Mark Levin you know I one day I'm gonna
put you on and talk about the story I
forced you to do radio let's be honest
about this you I don't want to do it and
I made I need you fill in for me and
made you work for free for a year on
weekends and that's a one of the one of
the highlights of my career my friend
how are you and see that the world's
never been different listen mark when I
read the judge on Friday I thought of
you years ago you wrote an incredible
book it's called men in black and you
wrote other the liberty amendments
recently and an American tyranny what
some Liberty verse on so many of them
okay no these are all great books cuz
you're a constitutional scholar you see
what is happening you've heard what that
judge said Friday they're putting the
screws to man afford it has nothing to
do with collusion they want him to sing
be careful because he may not just sing
he may compose and I was proud of that
judge because that judge nailed it and
now you see Sarah Carter's report
tonight call me and Muller coordinating
tell me why this is so wrong and the
audience well let's hope the judge is
not just the gasbag and actually does
something about what he said
dragged us all back if we well for a few
minutes to the Constitution okay because
that's the bottom line then this is
where it's gonna wind up in the Attorney
General in the Deputy Attorney General
really have to answer some fundamental
questions about this investigation mr.
Muller wants to interview the president
and he wants to interview him under the
most onerous circumstances what is the
purpose of an interview like that based
on those 49 general areas his purpose is
to indict the president now what's the
purpose of in dining the president to
try the president and to find him guilty
what's the purpose of a conviction it's
to remove the President of the United
States from office that's the bottom
line no president has ever been indicted
while in office not one no president has
ever been forced before a federal grand
jury not one no president has ever been
removed from office by the United States
Senate and two-thirds vote of the Senate
not one
Muller's purpose his purpose is to
remove the president that means one man
got it that means one man one jury would
usurp the power the entire
constitutional power of Congress the
power to remove a president you can
indict every other public official a
judge for instance while they're in
office and go through the impeachment
process you cannot do it with a
president and I'm gonna tell you I've
been studying this for decades I'm
studying it now here's the authoritative
book so what's going on now takes
two-thirds of the Senate to remove a
president not one prosecutor not one
jury so my question is from a
constitutional perspective to Attorney
General Jeff Sessions it's time to step
up to the Deputy Attorney General it's
time to pay attention to the entire
country to all the lawyers you bring on
here this that is going on here now
these fights over whether he's going to
be subpoenaed the president whether he's
going to answer questions whether he can
be indicted in office I want people to
understand that the framers never even
contemplated what's going on today
they never contemplated that one
prosecutor a civil servant a bureaucrat
appointed by somebody else what had the
power to effectively remove
Prez in the United States the reason why
the Democrats are hanging their hat on
Muller the reason why the media are
hanging their hat on Muller they'll
never get 2/3 in the Senate to remove
this president I don't care if they'll
teach them they'll never get 2/3 it's
never happened before so what they're
hoping to do is trap them in this this
notion of a subpoena in questioning
indict them trying to humiliate them try
and force them in front of a court hope
that they get the Supreme Court on their
side which I doubt they will but you
never know with these courts and then
get them to resign that's their game
plan you heard it here first this is
very very important from a
constitutional perspective as I speak
mr. Muller is undermining the
Constitution he's not upholding the rule
of law whether he's consulting with
Comey are consulting with Nostradamus my
point is that that's going on right now
his anti-constitutional that'll mean the
undermining our system the framers
wanted the body politic to decide on
whether or not to remove one branch of
government just as the body politic put
that person there in the first place the
media are too ignorant
they're too liberal they're too obsessed
to understand this what I'm hoping
tonight with a few minutes here the
American people will you know I call you
the great one one of the best things I
or greatest accomplishments of my life
was convincing you to fill in for my
radio show and it did take convincing it
reward wasn't easy
mark you are your your your knowledge of
our framers and our founders and our
Constitution is second and nobody well
these words tonight are important I
agree with every one of them we love
having you on don't forget every Sunday
night the number one show on cable Life
Liberty Levin hosted by the great one my
friend Mark Levin thank you sir